Hey Thoughty2 here.
Looking your best sometimes takes a bit of
effort, whether it’s a few hours shopping
for jeans that don’t make your legs look
like two toothpicks sticking out a watermelon,
or getting every single hair in its right
place.
I know, your hair can be cruel sometimes.
But putting blood, sweat and tears into our
appearance, sometimes very literally, is not
a new thing; mankind has been doing it for
thousands and thousands of years.
Apes were barely out of the trees before they
started wondering if they’d look better
with banana skins over their nipples and a
few crocodile teeth through their ear lobes.
So today we look at some of the most extreme
modifications that people have made to their
own bodies.
In Skee Lo’s famous love poem from 1995
he wrote “I wish I was a little bit taller,
I wish I was a baller, I wish I had a girl
who looked good, I would call her”.
And while the last two are possible, through
practice and Tinder, your height is something
you’re stuck with as it’s down to your
skeleton.
Stuff like boobs, noses and eyelids are changeable,
your skeleton is set though, isn’t it?
Well not as much as you’d think and if you
get to work on it early enough, you can put
in some serious interior design changes.
Binding involves wrapping bandages or chords
very tightly around body parts for many months
and slowly changing the shape and alignment
of the bones.
It’s normally done on infants as they are
much more malleable.
The most extreme form is cranial deformation
or head binding, which has occurred all over
the world and is still does occasionally in
places like Polynesia and Congo.
At birth, the skull is made up of 44 separate
bone elements, which are connected with tissues
called fontanelles, that allow the rapid brain
expansion that occurs at a young age.
Over time, many of these 44 parts fuse together
but, surprisingly, the skull never actually
stops growing.
Your cheekbones continuously draw back and
your forehead keeps pushing forward.
That’s right, you’re getting a flat face.
But before the fusing occurs, you can bind
up the skull and elongate it over a period
of months.
In many cultures, such as the people of Tomman
Island, the practice is often done, since
a long head is associated with wisdom.
For the Mayans it was thought to be aesthetically
pleasing.
It’s also thought that some cultures were
trying to emulate other tribes who naturally
had this longer head since a mummified female
body found in Peru contained a fetus with
an elongated skull, meaning it must have been
genetic rather than caused artificially.
In China, the practice of foot binding lasted
almost 1000 years, where young girls’ feet
were wrapped to make them as small as possible.
It was thought to make them more attractive
and it saved them a fortune since they could
buy their Converse from the kid’s section.
Similar to binding is the practice of using
rings.
The most famous, of course, are the neck rings
but it is a common misconception that you
are stretching the neck, somehow lengthening
the vertebrae.
In fact, the weight of the rings acts to push
down the collar bone and the upper ribs, to
give the illusion of a longer, giraffe like
neck, but it is actually just shortening the
body.
The practice still happens in some areas of
northern Thailand and Myanmar and parts of
Africa.
The rings can end up weighing as much as 10
kilos and they either start at around 2 years
old, since it’s less painful to do it slowly
over time, or at age 12, when they are considered
ready to marry.
I think they’ve been listening to too much
Beyonce; you don’t have to put a ring on
that.
It’s not exactly sure how the practice started.
Obviously it’s seen as elegant and beautiful
but some people also theorize that it was
protection against tiger attack.
It’s the same reason all British people
wear ankle bracelets, in case we are attacked
by badgers, or is that just me?
As for the human bite, well it’s pretty
pathetic compared to many of our animal brethren.
Although there are a surprising amount of
human bite attacks, over a thousand per year
in New York alone.
And if you want to add a bit more bite to
your bite, then it’s time for some extreme
dentistry.
Teeth sharpening occurs in many pockets all
over the world, from the Congolese to parts
of Vietnam and South America.
It’s often an aesthetic practice, done with
a chisel, but in Bali, teeth are thought to
represent negative emotions such as anger
and jealousy and so are filed down to lessen
this.
For the Mayans it was a class based system
so a fancy set of sharp fangs was the equivalent
of some red trousers and a glass of pimms.
Holes, we all have them and they are a source
of never ending hilarity and embarrassment.
Most mammals have the same selection of orifices
as we do, except for a few types of mole which
have a thing called cloaca, which is one orifice
that has the combined use for excretion, urine
and reproduction; now that’s just disgusting.
The cloaca is standard for all amphibians,
birds and reptiles though.
Some mollusks have a thing called a siphon
which lets water, or occasionally air, flow
through, used for a combination of movement,
feeding, breathing and reproduction.
I just hope they clean it between each one.
But humans have a habit of creating artificial
holes which they then fill with piercings
or gradually expand using a series of rings.
The ancient Egyptian King, Tutankhamun, is
one of the earliest recorded examples of ear
stretching since you can see it depicted on
his sarcophagus.
The 5000 year old Ötzi the Iceman, who was
discovered in the Himalayas, also had flesh
tunnels.
His My Chemical Romance t-shirt had unfortunately
not survived though.
In some Hindu culture a woman’s nose was
pierced as a sign she was ready to be married.
It was typically the left nostril too as that
was thought to relieve some of the pain of
childbirth.
In ancient times, it would also help her attach
more jewelry to her face, which was important
since anything worn for the wedding was hers
to keep while everything else became her husbands,
so a chain between your nose and ear would
have been very handy for hanging diamonds,
car keys and the remote control.
A quick mention too for the lip plate, popular
in East Africa and parts of the Amazon basin,
which normally involves a piercing in the
upper or lower lip and then a wooden disk
inserted to stretch it out.
Actually, I could do with one of those at
Christmas, would make shoveling food into
my face so much easier.
And finally, from dolphins on your ankles
to “this westerner is an idiot” written
in Japanese kanji, it’s the wonderful world
of tattooing.
Various forms of tattooing have existed since
Neolithic times, perhaps even further back
but we don’t have direct evidence of it.
Otzi the Iceman, who we mentioned before,
had tattoo markings to go along with his pierced
ears and his skin is the oldest example we
have found so far.
There are wide ranges of reasons and designs
for tattoos, from the detailed full body tribal
images to markings on the arms and face, to
indicate a slave or perhaps a criminal.
In Europe, tattooing was less common from
the middle of the second millennium but it
was reintroduced by Captain Cook and his crew
after a trip to Tahiti.
The word Tattoo itself comes from the Tahitian
Tatau and many of Cook’s crew came back
with tattoos, which soon started a trend on
the high-seas and made them associated with
sailors and subsequently, the criminal classes.
They still have a negative, criminal association
in places like Japan and are strongly discouraged
by many parts of the Islamic world, but around
45 million Americans have one or more tattoos
and a third of British people.
Making them extremely common, so, if you are
thinking of trying to rebel, you would actually
be better off getting a side parting, putting
on a sensible jumper and smoking a pipe.
The rich history of body modification has
given us some weird and wonderful traditions
and let’s hope that some keep going, so
the entire planet doesn’t end up looking
exactly the same.
If you’re thinking about starting your own
cultural tradition, go ahead, but please call
you mum before you stick that thing through
there, I’m not sure it’s the best idea
you’ve ever had.
Thanks for
the view, subscribe for more Thoughty2.